[Music]
consider
a vector in a three-dimensional
coordinate system
recall that a vector is a mathematical
quantity
that has magnitude as well as direction
a vector is represented by an arrow
varied points will tell you the
direction of that vector
and the length of the arrow represents
the magnitude of that vector
this is a vector whose initial point
sits on the origin
but just so that you know in 3d geometry
we will have vectors like this also
whose initial point
is not at the origin okay
now let's name this vector as vector a
it's making some angles with the
positive x-axis
positive y-axis and the positive z-axis
it makes 60 degrees with positive x-axis
120 degrees with positive y-axis
and 45 degrees with positive z-axis
we call these three angles made by a
vector with positive
x y and z axis the direction angles of
the vector
and generally we use greek letters like
alpha beta and gamma
to represent these angles where alpha is
the angle a vector makes with positive
x-axis beta and gamma are the angles
that a vector makes
with positive y and z-axis respectively
also the range of each direction angle
is between
0 and pi including both 0
and pi it is a condition or criterion
that ensures uniqueness to simplify
things for our convenience
we want every vector on a 3d plane
passing through the origin
to have a unique set of direction angles
i will elaborate more on this in a
moment
so to put it in plain words the
direction angles are the angles
that a vector makes with the positive x
y
and z axis
intuitively you can think of direction
angles
as a way to represent the direction of a
vector
in 3d space from a given set of
direction angles
we can tell where a vector is directed
note that the direction angles do not
tell us anything about the magnitude of
a vector
they will only tell you about its
direction
for example a vector twice the magnitude
and in the same direction will have the
same set of direction angles
now here's an example of a vector that
lies on the
x-z plane it makes 135 degrees with the
positive
x-axis 45 degrees with the positive
z-axis
how much does it make with y-axis
since it's fully inside the x-z plane
it will make a 90 degree angle with the
positive y-axis
so its direction angles are as follows
so these examples were taken just to
show you that a direction angle can be
acute
obtuse or a right angle
i want to elaborate on a point that i
made earlier
about the range of these angles let's go
back to our earlier example
where a vector is clearly visible in the
second octant
here it makes an angle 60 degrees with
the positive side of the x-axis
but it can also make an angle from the
other side or from the other direction
with a positive x-axis
and that angle will be 360 degrees minus
60 degrees
we will get a reflex angle meaning
greater than 180 degrees or pi
so if it was not for the condition alpha
can be either of these two
angles similarly beta
and gamma can be either of these two
angles in which
one of the two possible angles is a
reflex
so as you can see there can be eight
possible sets of direction
angles for this vector but
by laying down this condition we are
breaking it down to
one unique set and in which there will
be no
angle greater than 180 degrees
all right we will end the video here
in the next video we will talk about the
direction angles of a line
thank you for watching
you